what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have some
pretty exciting news for those scarlet
witch fans out there for those shang qi
and the legend of the 10 rings fans out
there and the brooklyn nine-nine fans
out there as weird as that sounds but
it'll all make sense in just a bit it
looks like we are getting the scarlet
witch back in the mcu it could be as
early on as next year if you were
thinking that the scarlet witch died at
the end of doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness that does not
appear to be the case as expected by
many many people and now it looks like
she's going to be returning in some
other mcu projects and then of course
her own mcu project relatively soon and
yesterday the news broke that a wonder
man series is actively in development
over at marvel studios for disney plus
with shangchi director destin daniel
[ __ ] and community in brooklyn 99
scribe andrew guest these two are going
to be handling the wonder man series and
we have a little bit of new information
about that today and speaking of xiang
chi sima liu and chloe bennett were
recently spotted together they both
posted pictures of themselves on
instagram of course chloe plays daisy
johnson aka quake in agents of shield
and you have to wonder if something is
going on here could a crossover be
happening soon or is this just simply
the two of them hanging out a lot to
talk about today so let's dive into it
and of course if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos so let's first
start off by talking about the scarlet
witch because she seems to be a huge fan
favorite right now i love her myself and
a lot of people were wondering if she
was going to be returning to the mcu if
she was really dead at the end of
multiverse of madness and for those who
believed that she wasn't dead the big
question is when she returns is she
going to be good or is she going to be
evil we'll tackle that question in just
a bit but recently doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness writer michael
waldron came out and said that the
ending is kind of left open for your own
interpretation so he pretty much neither
confirmed or denied that the scarlet
witch was dead but of course if they're
all not talking about the end of
elizabeth olsen playing the scarlet
witch and the scarlet witch being done
that pretty much means she is alive and
besides the scarlet witch took on the
entire illuminati i'm pretty sure she
can handle some rocks falling on top of
her so i've been saying that of course
she is not dead and ever since the movie
came out a bunch of insiders have been
talking about when she's going to appear
next confirming that she is indeed still
alive and today we have a report from
insider daniel rpk who has a great track
record with his scoops who says not only
did wanda survive the events of
multiverse of madness but she'll be back
for one of the mcu's upcoming projects
filming next year now like you heard a
wonder man disney plus show is being
developed right now by marvel studios
and grace randolph says that she hears
that wonder man on disney plus is going
to be a comedy and that wanda is being
considered for the show and she's even
kind of comparing it saying that it's
going to be kind of like a one division
season 2. and this kind of makes sense
if you consider the history between the
scarlet witch vision and wonder man so
wonder man's real name is simon williams
and in the comics vision's brainwaves
are actually created from simon
williams's brain waves simon williams's
brain waves were the template for
creating visions and wanda vision and
wonder man are kind of in a little bit
of a love triangle in the comics in the
comics they hint that the only reason
vision really likes wanda is because
simon liked wanda and now they have the
same brainwaves but simon williams never
told wanda this it's unclear if he was
even aware of it at the time but once
when wanda and vision actually get
together wonder man realizes that he has
feelings for wanda and is pretty bummed
out about it now there's a lot to the
story but basically for the point of
this wonder man series and the scarlet
witch returning in the mcu what happens
is is we get white vision and he loses
all of his emotions so wanda goes to
wonder man and asks him if he could lend
his brain waves again to give vision his
emotions again in which he actually says
no because he has feelings for wanda and
doesn't want her to be with vision
however eventually he does cave and he
says okay but white vision does not want
them he says i have to go out and i have
to discover my emotions for myself and
get my own personality not your
personality so he leaves and eventually
when he leaves wonder man and wanda get
together and it's also very important to
know that in the comics wonder man dies
but wanda actually resurrects him in his
ionic form this is pretty much exactly
what we saw in one division one to
resurrected vision in kind of an ionic
form as well because obviously the
vision wasn't permanent and could not
live outside of the bubble that wanna
created just like her kids however we
did have white vision or spectral vision
as some people call him he appeared at
the end of one division and he left and
he kind of left to really discover who
exactly he was after the real vision our
vision kind of made him see everything
that had happened to him so i'm actually
kind of expecting the scarlet witch to
show up in the series now since it's
being rumored and i would not be
surprised in the slightest if vision
returned as well now the end of one
division obviously set up the return for
spectral vision we just didn't know when
he was going to return but this makes a
lot of sense and like i just mentioned
with the whole history of the scarlet
witch in wonder man it would make sense
for the scarlet witch to show up as well
perhaps these two will have a love
interest in the mcu after all wanda did
a lot to look for her kids however she
didn't really do anything to look for
vision or at least tried to resurrect
him and restore his memories in some
type of android i think vision was
mentioned maybe twice in multiverse of
madness could that be because there's
about to be a whole storyline with
wonder man now granted vision is not
made the same way in the mcu as he has
created in the comics so in the mcu he
should not have the brainwaves of simon
williams but this show wonder man is
actually supposed to be a comedy in fact
some new information today says that it
could be a hollywood satire according to
joe otterson a writer at variety he said
on twitter i have also heard that this
show could be a hollywood satire but
that is not 100 confirmed it would make
sense given wonder man's backstory as an
actor and stuntman in the comics and i
actually think that this would be pretty
cool we could have a superhero or at
least an enhanced individual in the mcu
who uses his powers to actually become
famous to be a famous actor kind of like
kingo although i'm not really sure how
much kingo's powers helped him become
famous it was pretty much his
immortality that helped him become
famous just over the years so this would
be different this would be somebody with
actual superpowers using those to his
advantage to get on screen as an actor i
think if they do go the comedy route it
would also be pretty funny to kind of
break the fourth wall like have simon
williams go audition for a marvel movie
and kevin feige's there and maybe some
old x-men actors like hugh jackman i
just think it would be really fun and i
think that this could be done extremely
well and i'm really hoping that the
scarlet witch does return and maybe even
vision as well because this could be a
pretty funny comedy if you have like
this little bit of a love triangle thing
here that way it's not so serious it's
not that heavy which i think would be
nice considering how heavy doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
was and if wanda is going to come back
and try to be a hero again it would make
sense that she would come back for
something that's a little bit
light-hearted and then work up to hey
you kind of did some stuff but the
avengers kind of need you right now and
it seems like you're okay after all she
didn't affect our universe too much at
least not that we know of yet she did
kill a bunch of sorcerers which of
course is horrible but she didn't
destroy any cities civilians weren't
really affected and nobody really saw
what she did except for all of the
people at the carmitage and of course
they're all gonna be super pissed about
it and who knows what wong's gonna say
but i'm assuming that once the next big
huge threat comes they're gonna want
wanda on their side and there's been a
lot of talk about the scarlet witch
coming back for a solo a true solo
scarlet witch film not a doctor strange
in the scarlet witch film but a scarlet
witch film i really hope that happens
and it's nice to know that the scarlet
witch should be returning before then so
let me know your thoughts about this in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos for live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
me